I don't give a [ __ ] if Mark Zucker  Zuckerberg's cage side do your thing  dude yeah I'll see you and Dan are boys  now whatever bro you're not the  president United States you're not Putin  we don't need to stop this thing because  somebody's coming with a [ __ ] bomb  strapped to their no one gives a [ __ ]  about Facebook you know who's more  controversial than him and he's at every  major pay-per-view is Joe Rogan way more  controversial than Mark Zuckerberg  this guy because he's a billionaire we  it's everyone's like okay that's cool I  don't think it's cool I also [ __ ] up  the fighters so he puts like we're told  casual confirm bro rent out the entire  Apex and only showed up for me card  it's like it's straight he rented out an  entire Arena and then just showed up  for the main card you didn't watch the  prelims